Once you've decided the vision of your business,...
...the most important thing is to find employees to help you bring that vision to life.
When you're hiring employees, you need to really figure out...
...what the most important trait for your company is.
Wine can be intimidating.
We need to have employees that are approachable to our clients.
A willingness to learn is so important because it helps your employees grow within your company,...
...and that ultimately helps your company to grow too.
You can always teach your employees more about your product,...
...but they have to have the passion within them to sell it for you.
It's your business, it's your vision.
You need to hire great employees that help you meet those goals.